[Applause]
it was the first combat veteran of
either Iraq or Afghanistan to be elected
to the United States Congress three
terms of three tours over there he's now
serving his fifth term from California's
50th Duncan Hunter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
glad to have you back I'm very impressed
that you were showed up thanks for
having me
well you're a Republican you were a
Trump's first supporter but I bill
Marfan but I really appreciate it you
know and I'm gonna make you a deal so I
know you have a little campaign finance
trouble of your own sure okay and most
of the hosts would ask you about that
let's let that go okay kiss campaign
finance is tricky business it is the
Department of Justice's tricky business
here's my deal I'll let that go but you
got an answer honestly about Donald
Trump okay don't little [ __ ] me about
Donald Trump deal okay so you're a
veteran Yeah right three tours right
through to Afghanistan and Iraq right
okay
the way they're treating McCain this
came from Trump originally it's he
didn't like he didn't like people who
get captured and now we saw this week
this guy on Fox News say torture works
we know it because that because it
worked on McCain that's what they called
him
pretty rotten yeah I'm not know the
torture thing is different but those are
bad you shouldn't make fun of people
when they're dying but when you and I
pass away I'm sure some people are gonna
tweet bad things about us I think with
the over sensationalism and everything
being on on the 24-hour news cycle and
the tweets you're gonna have bad people
say thing you're gonna people say bad
things about everybody that dies
everybody not asking you about you're a
veteran well but Trump didn't say this
about Trump said originally about McCain
and then somebody in his White House
that a rotten thing about who cares what
his vote is he's dying anyway come on
this doesn't bother you and other
veterans know a guy who was five-years
enough to be honest let me try to be
honest we make fun I mean because we're
in the military so it's hard to ask
somebody who's been in the military and
has made every crass joke known to man
as bad as you can get worse than you
make I mean really bad jokes
yeah it's I've made the same John McCain
joke with my friends who are other other
Marines right
he if I was a pilot as opposed to a
ground pounder on the ground I'd be a
better pilot I wouldn't get shot down
right I've made that joke but can I make
it to my friends on on national TV as
the the contender for the US presidency
but it shouldn't be done Donald Trump is
a draft dodger he supported the war let
other people go for him I mean to make
fun of a guy who was tortured - how long
do you think Donald Trump would last
under torture not not very long
he probably torture his torturers
talking about the election
you know nobody thought I could get to
300 please
so torture I mean this is a big topic
now because we're about to or maybe we
did already what happened with Gina
Haskell Gina hospital what's her name I
think hospital hospital she's up to be
the head of the Society confirmed and
I'll tell you probably will be confirmed
I differ with McCain on on the core but
she did oversee torture back in the day
when it was the Bush admitted when it
was needed I think when you're talking
about al-qaeda and you're talking about
Isis and and I don't call it torture was
call it into it let's call it really
mean interrogation techniques let's come
on they're not on the medieval rackets
Lauren she it is rave heart oh stop they
over it they people were in stress
positions for a week no I'm just like
these are all good people look if
somebody was part of 9/11 yeah they get
what this coming to them but when we
torture people then you're a veteran but
we don't view or capture they would
torture you you are American we
interrogate terrorists we don't we don't
do this to if we're if those Russian
mercenaries will be killed we kill about
a hundred Russian mercenaries in Syria
about two months ago
that's a different thing that people
that are gonna put you in a cage and
burn you alive they're gonna chop your
head off on TV that's what Isis does and
if they have nukes they're gonna use
them here and our Center than Isis I'm
going better that's necessary that we
have available to make sure that we
don't get a nuke in this country or get
hit again like like 9/11 now I have no
problem with that truly none okay well
this was after 9/11 and they didn't get
any valuable information doesn't mean
that guys still aren't trying to do the
same thing now right okay moving on it's
not easy to get down are you Kagura okay
so the military budget but I know you're
a big fan of it do you throw it line by
line you are a con yes we go through it
line by line and you think because a lot
of I read it line by line
and a lot of this stuff the Pentagon
asks for like we want 70 planes that's
what the Pentagon is asking for and
Congress gives them 90
isn't that socialism when you're just
making things just to give jobs to
people no because that's not why we're
doing it well but wait the Pentagon let
me give you an example what more than
that the Pentagon is asked let me give
you a great example in the late 90s the
Air Force did not want this crazy thing
called an unmanned aerial vehicle
why would pilots who run the air force
want an unmanned aerial vehicle so they
said no Congress said you're gonna have
it it's the future and they hoisted the
predator unmanned aerial vehicle on the
Air Force we made them take it so that
that's an example of how you're in the
military so you're in in the box and you
have no other perspective but that
military perspective that's why we have
civilian control of the military so we
have a Congress that's why you have
secretaries and you don't have generals
or anything but a civilian as the
president this villain has the so the
Congress knows better than the Pentagon
what on something needs on some things
yeah absolutely let me tell you one too
we have one icebreaker you know that
breaks ice right that support for the
Arctic we have one the Russians have 45
the the military doesn't always do the
acquisition stuff very well because
because they only do two years of
deterrent in there in northern country
you know where we don't but you know in
the in the first six months of this year
the national debt went up to one
trillion dollars and of course on Fox
News they're saying Weddell the
Republicans take over that'll land
how do you explain this I mean you guys
run on fiscal sanity and how everybody
else has to spend is a spender but then
when you get into office the money just
flies out the window so here's what
happened on this it's pretty simple you
had over you had just under four times
the deaths last year last calendar year
2017 January through December you had
almost four times as many deaths
training in the military that in combat
you had 23 or so combat deaths Iraq
Afghanistan Syria Philippines places all
over where we have people you had over
80 training deaths here in the
continental United States that's crazy
the the Defense Department was
chronically underfunded for eight years
under Obama period and you had massive
training casualties now that showed how
bad the equipment was especially the
airplanes because all the good stuffs
going forward and all the training stuff
is getting worse and worse and worse
right
so we had to plus up the defense budget
and in order to get that passed the
Senate that giant budget that was not
funded to a vote for except for the
military part that that was what we had
to do and that's what I had to do so it
was to save life yeah it was for the
military part of the budget yeah the
Senate exacts a very high cost to get
anything done otherwise they'll do
nothing yeah the Senate does nothing
anyway I hate to take the the the the
the the budget could be a zillion
dollars which it probably will be next
year there was still will be training
deaths but not as many that this was
getting pretty massive you had a massive
spike in training just due to a lower
but so you are you're glad that Trump
pull out of the Iran deal yes and let me
so you can look at the Iran deal at the
same way you look at North Korea right
you had a lot of people pooh-poohing
unilateral action moving our giant
fleets to South Korea moving people into
South Korea getting ready for career war
all right that's what we were doing
people people put that down massively
now we see what's happening on June 12th
I think you see the same thing with the
Iranian deal I simply don't trust the
Iranians I think they have a I mean
that's everybody who I listed in the
monologue there has said that the they
were including general mattis said I
read it three times I doubt if Trump has
read it once
right that's the president's take okay
what mister he he said this verification
is really robust I mean there are met
they have been many inspections
everybody has said even the Israelis who
were against the deal have said the
inspections are working Iran is
complying except for those places in it
looks in Tehran where she does not
allowed to inspect what places it does
military installations military
installations is there like super deep
underground bunkers where they have
these centrifuges and you get realized
they already have enough uranium now low
low-grade uranium to put on a very large
missile meaning the less enriched your
your your uranium is the bigger than
missile you have to have they already
have that they probably already have the
missiles right now right and and all the
jcpoa did the joint comprehensive plan
of action that trump pulled out of that
just pushed them off ten years and not
being able to validate everything but
they came out of it at ten years and we
could fill it in five years in ten years
we could bring them into the family of
nations that's what the I think we can
do that now the same way he just didn't
do that now meanwhile they're chanting
death to America in the Parliament in
North unit is the same time but you know
that you did them such a big favor
because the the country is really on the
brink the economy is terrible and the
people there were very furious at the
government and now they're furious at us
I don't think so of course is now I
think they have seen what the Iranians
have done with the money that they got
from going into the the jcpoa buying
arms supporting Hamas and Hezbollah
doing very bad things with the money
that we as taxpayers gave them that's
what the Iranians have been doing with
the money
III think the people in Iran want their
crazy religious government to go away so
they can be more like us and and they're
happy to have us help them in any way
possible and your method is to strangle
them economically yeah that's what's
gonna win them over
yeah the government that's okay worked
in Norway I mean what okay so why
there's so many Russian connections with
the Trump administration and do you
worry about democracy being in trouble
around the world and here at home I wish
I had an answer for you it's strange and
I think Trump had a lot of sleazy people
working for him
that and he didn't necessarily know I
don't think he knew that : who's had all
of these side deals I don't think that
he knew that manna for had all of these
side deals really because I don't think
Trump's down and in their business
ideally and saying I want to know
exactly what you're signing for it seems
like everybody had some connection with
Russians and all these meetings with
Russians and all the lies about the
Russians everything comes up Russia
Russia Russia Russia like Marcia Marcia
Marcia they have the money you don't
think there's any connection there you
don't think it's a little collusion II
know I think no yeah not with Trump but
I think you I don't think that was the
case I mean you're enough of a patriot
to have joined up and fought in for this
country overseas in two theaters if it
turned if you want to compare though
what all of these different things that
we see in the media right now with the
actual payments made to the Clinton
Foundation but that's not a talking
point those are real things it you have
that's been in the Clinton Foundation
for [ __ ] no but we did I can't
they're breaking my deal okay breaking
the deal you are breaking the deal you
have you know that's you have you have
nothing straight up with Trump and and
the Russians nothing nothing that these
these kind of sleazy guys around him
that are now getting in in trouble but
Trump is not I don't think Trump knew
what was going on okay
should he testify Bill Clinton had to
testify for four hours about the [ __ ]
shouldn't he to avoid a gradually why
shouldn't he shouldn't Trump have to
answer questions about a foreign power
meddling in our government no I don't
think you shouldn't ask really yeah no I
think the deal and that's just just
partisanship no I'd be the rule of law
people remember the rule of law until
the log gets political in the Department
of Justice not in political so it wasn't
political wasn't political under Clinton
but now it is and Muller's the dirty
dyin trust an executive branch the the
Department of Justice is an executive
branch service meaning it's not under
Congress or anything it's under the
executive branch not this in the service
of the president and the service of the
nation no but it's in the executive
branch duty he appoints the Attorney
General right so the the Department of
Justice is under is under Trump kind of
right there is no oversight of the DOJ
no that's the case the Attorney General
who he appoints Percy's Department of
Justice but it's a separate entity
that's no true but it's but it's in the
executive okay like it apart at the
interior it's the same kind of thing
Thank You commander dummy I think you're
a great guy I really hope you lose your
next election
[Applause]